did you know that rich people don't pay
that much tax taxes were created for the
poor and middle class and i'm going to
show you in this video how you can avoid
not evade evade is illegal but how you
can avoid paying taxes when you
understand real estate i'm aware that
might offend people what do you mean pay
no taxes but listen i would advise you
and urge you to pay as little taxes you
can as long as it is legal i would
encourage you to get rich and then be a
compassionate capitalist and give money
to the charity
set up a foundation all these things but
right now this is about money and about
creating serious wealth through property
and i'm gonna be explaining exactly how
i've done it and how the rich invest in
property if you enjoy my channel do me a
favor first thing you need to do go
ahead and smash the like button
subscribe to the channel hit that like
button right now that's the first step
and then let's get started so generally
speaking there's two reasons why people
are gonna invest in property there's two
ways to make money in property the first
way is rent now rent is that you know
that thing that comes in every single
month you buy a house you rent it out
that's cash flow how people get rich
from real estate is from not from cash
flow but from capital appreciation
now capital appreciation is when you buy
a house and you hold on to it and then
it goes up in value that's how most
people get rich by mistake you know you
buy a house
you get a little bit of monthly cash
flow from it which is great and then
you're enjoying your passive income and
then a year two years five years later
you're like man i bought the house for
50 grand and now it's worth 100 grand um
or i bought the house for 100 grand and
now it's worth 200 grand historically
property prices double in value every 10
years now you might disagree with that
but listen this isn't my opinion this is
history i remember 10 12 years ago i'm
buying houses and everyone's like
they're definitely not going to double
this next 10 years though because of the
credit crunch and guess what they
doubled and then 10 years prior to that
in year 2000 or year in in the 90s same
story everyone's going to they're not
going to double in the next 10 though
and every year you can go about the last
10 the last 10 the last 10 the last 10
house prices keep doubling in value how
do you
get good capital appreciation property
prices do go up they don't however they
don't go up in value in a straight line
okay property prices go up in fact they
go up and then they go down and then
they go up and then they don't know what
they're going to do and then up more and
then down and then up but on average
overall they go up every expansion will
always follow a recession and after
every recession will always follow an
expansion so you know if properties are
bottomed out in an area if there's a
town or an outskirt of a town where
property prices have dropped you know
that they're gonna then bounce up i mean
what most people do because they're
uneducated see house prices go up really
high and they get all excited
and buy
and then of course
oh wow i did the right thing i'm so
excited i'm oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh has prices drop
and instead of holding on and just
thinking you know what i'm just going to
keep getting my nice monthly rent
and i'm just going to hold on they then
sell
and then they lose money whereas what
you want to do as a smart investor is
you want to wait until they've gone down
when they're bottomed out and then when
house prices drop you're then going to
buy
when everyone's scared when everyone
sent all properties of bottom down in
that area and then you want to buy
and then you're going to wait for the
properties then to bounce up and then
when the house goes up and you've made a
load of capital appreciation what are
you going to do
some people say well i'm going to sell
you could sell let's say you buy for a
hundred grand
hundred thousand pound you buy a little
house
gives you 500 pounds rent every month
nice a little bit of profit and that
house then went up in value and then say
let's say 10 years later the house is
worth 200 000 pounds
okay you've made
a hundred thousand pounds
equity now that isn't in your bank
you can't see it it's in
the bricks and mortar of the house but
you made a hundred thousand pounds
now if the only way you can generally
get to that hundred thousand pounds
profit is by selling the house
and if you sell the house you're going
to get your hundred thousand pounds
profit congratulations but the problem
is you're going to pay some serious tax
on that profit it currently capital
gains tax is 28
which is going to mean that you've paid
28 000 pounds to the hmrc which means
you're actually only going to be left in
your pocket with 72 000 pounds and 28
thousand pounds is going to go i've gone
to her majesty
but what
rich people tend to do and what i
certainly do and i've been doing over
the years is when your house doubles in
value and by the way when your house
doubles in value usually so does the
rent because house prices go up episode
of rent everything goes up over time so
your rent's gone up your house price has
gone up you bought it for a hundred now
it's worth 200 what you're gonna do well
instead of selling the house
and making a hundred thousand pounds and
paying tax and being left with 72 000 in
your pocket what you want to do is you
want to refinance
refinance the house see if you refinance
the house what that means is you're
gonna get a new mortgage
against the new value of the house so
you're going to borrow
generally speaking 75
and 75 of 200 is 150 000 pounds so
you're going to pull out the 150 000
pounds
you're going to pay off the existing
mortgage because presumably you bought
the house on a 75 mortgage in the first
place which is going to be 75 000 pound
mortgage
you're going to replace that 75 000
pound mortgage with 150 000 pound
mortgage but you're going to be left in
your pocket with 75 000 pounds tax free
that's more than you'd be left with in
your pocket if you sold it
and you still got the house
so you've still got the house which
means you've still got the rent of the
house which means that the house is
still continuing to give you a profit
and continuing to go up in value so you
have more money in your pocket and
you're still going to have the house so
you're still going to keep the rent
and you can just use that money what are
you going to use that 75 000 pounds to
do you're going to put it towards buying
another house and then when that house
goes up in value what are you going to
do refinance and then when you refinance
what are you going to do with the money
you're going to buy another house and
you're going to buy another house and
another house and you're just going to
keep on keep on keep on building your
portfolio snowballing that wealth and
your rent's going to be going up your
net worth is going to be going up and
that is how rich people grow their
portfolio now let me tell you something
you'll never learn this
in school
they'll never teach you this in school
the system doesn't want you to be rich
so you've got to take responsibility
you've got to study this yourself you've
got to understand not just how to make
money but also how to invest it because
otherwise your whole life just working
for somebody else i really enjoy
teaching people about real estate if you
enjoy my channel hit subscribe share the
video people need to be educated about
investments
[Music]
you